what's going on everyone it's axelbeatz
here for anime uproar and as you all
know the naruto series is one which
heavily discusses the ideas of loss and
war and as such today we will be
discussing every character death in
naruto if you enjoy this video and you
want to see more naruto content on this
channel remember to leave a like as well
as a comment down below it only takes a
second but it really does help with the
youtube algorithm and of course if you
haven't subscribed to anime uproar make
this the video that you do so by
clicking that bell and selecting all
notifications you can also follow anime
opera on twitter and instagram at anime
uproar or you can follow myself at
excellionyt
if you are interested after this video i
also have a video on my own channel all
about how death is used in anime i think
it's a really good one so if you're
interested please go check it out i'll
have gozan or animak leave it in the pin
comment down below finally of course
this video will contain spoilers as we
are talking about character death
through both naruto and shippuden it's
kind of hard to avoid spoilers when
we're doing that but if you're not
worried about that then it's time to get
into it so some ground rules here
firstly this video will only be
discussing characters who actually
matter to some degree i am not going to
spend two hours listing off all of the
ninjas that matara killed in his
introduction battle nameless purposeless
characters will typically be passed over
secondly this video will discuss the
deaths in more or less chronological
order as best as i can we're gonna start
all the way back with the sage of six
paths and all his backstory stuff
and then move forward towards the actual
end of shipudin finally if we don't know
their cause of death we're probably just
gonna skip it for example asura is
obviously dead he was alive hundreds and
hundreds of years ago but we don't
really know what happened to him so
we're just gonna move on past that we
probably have to start with the era
before the warring states period i know
is kaguya's servant who led her into
hiding when people were looking to
capture her eventually aino decided to
jump in front of kaguya to protect her
from a flurry of arrows
tanji was the emperor from the land of
ancestors who fell in love with kauria
they did the hanky-panky but when kagia
killed an army from the land of that
with her powers tenji began to fear her
kaguya would eat the fruit of the god
tree and cast infinite tsukiomi trapping
tenji and eventually killing him suzaku
and genbu were both ministers from the
land of that who were also trapped in
the infinite tsukuyomi shiro was asura
and indira's pet dog who died protecting
asura from a wild boar hamura otsuki was
kaguya and tanji's child and the brother
of haguromo and he's also the ancestor
to the huga clan he would be brainwashed
by kaguya and forced to fight his
brother a fight which would result in
them taking on the ten tails together at
the end of it and ultimately separating
it into the tailed beasts sometime after
losing he would choose to go back to the
moon to watch over kalgria where he
would die surrounded by his clan the
sage of six past hagoromo utsuki rather
than returning to the moon like hamura
did chose to stay on earth to find
proper homes for the tale beasts and to
spread the teaching of ninju he would
have two children indra and ashrae
choosing to entrust asura with leading
ninju into the future as he died
kawarama senju and itama senju were
brothers of the first okage hashirama
and were killed during the ongoing senju
uchiha war
similarly izuna uchiha was killed by
tobi rama during the conflict as well
in the first shinobi war what is
probably one of the most impactful
deaths throughout the entire war was
mahra uchiha who was the leader of the
uchiha clan he and hashirama were
considered to be the greatest living
ninja at the time and had a lifelong
rivalry which ultimately came to a head
with hashirama finally managing to kill
madra however madra would revive himself
using izanagi to avoid this fate
it is also the case that many others
died through this war as you know it's a
war but we don't really have all that
much information on the actual cause of
death for these characters however there
are a few who are too relevant to not
really include so for example hashirama
senju the first hokage
a the first raikage biakuren the first
mizukage and ishikawa the first
tsuchikage all died during this conflict
as well presumably from combat reto who
was the first kazekage however was
killed by assassins it wasn't just the
first of their kind though as many of
the second kage died in this conflict as
well this includes tobirama senju's team
who was surrounded by kinkaku's forces
and tobirama chose to sacrifice himself
to allow his comrades to escape also
declaring heroes in saratobi as the
third hokage at the same time and
speaking of hirozin his father sasuke
sarutobi also died during this war the
second reikage also died during this
same attack by kinkaku and ginkaku that
killed toby rama genn getsu hozuki the
second mizukage and mu the second
tsuchikage each died in combat with each
other and again just like the first
shamon the second kazekage was killed by
assassins i would not want to be a
kazekage during the second shinobi world
war much like the first one we have a
few characters whose deaths just aren't
that detailed these include kinkaku
ginkaku and the third mizukage furui a
jonan from the hidden cloud was killed
by the eight tails blue bee the third
reikage traded his own life to seal the
eight tails into the purifying pot
nawaki was tsunada's younger brother and
much like naruto he wanted to be the
hokage however the day after his
birthday he would go into battle being
blown to bits by an explosive trap and
while recovering people tsunade gave her
necklace to the man she loved dan kado
was also killed in battle during this
war as well nagato's parents were both
killed by leaf shinobi in front of him
and marked his first great moment of
pain mito uzumaki a previous nine-tailed
jinchuriki and the wife of hashirama was
killed when the nine tails was removed
from her and the last three for this era
all revolve around kakashi's father
sakumo hatake sasuri's father and mother
were both killed by sakumo and sakamot
himself would go on to take his own life
after choosing the survival of his own
team over the completion of his mission
a decision which turned him into an
outcast for betraying their cause and
led him into a deep depression in the
third shinobi war the third reikage died
when fighting off an army of ten
thousand shinobi on his own mahiru
taiseki and kako were stone ninja who
most notably captured rin to try and get
information out of her they were killed
by minato obito and kakashi respectively
the third kazekage was kidnapped and
killed by sorcery and turned into a
puppet might guy's father might die also
managed to kill four ninja in this war
to protect his son despite gai being an
eternal genin he managed to use the
eight gates and this allowed him to
defeat jinin akibo kushimaru kuyarare
jinpachi munashi and the unnamed
previous user of the hiramakere which is
pretty impressive and heartwarming
however this ultimately did end in might
die losing his own life as well as he
had opened the eighth gate many of the
original members of the original
akatsuki were also killed in this
conflict kier daibutsu and kyusuke were
each killed by either obito or zetsu and
of course yahiko who was nagato's best
friend ended his own life to protect his
friends by jumping onto nagato's kunai
as a sacrifice to hanzo this death would
lead into nagato going into a rage and
would be his second moment of pain and
of course one of the most impactful
deaths in the entire series rin ohara
rin had been made into ajinchuriki and
sacrificed herself by jumping into
kakashi's chidori obito witnessed this
and ultimately led him down the path
that madara had laid out for him finally
speaking of mara uchiha he would finally
die of old age as well around this time
and leading from the shinobi war to the
beginning of the actual series we have
several deaths as well most of which
were pivotal in setting up the
characters and plots of the actual
series
hanzo the salamander who was both the
leader of the hidden reign and also was
ultimately the cause of yahiko's death
was understandably killed by pain this
allowed the akatsuki and more
specifically nagato to take control of
the hidden reign in this period gara's
mother karura also died in childbirth
and years later karura's brother yasha
maru would blow himself up trying to
kill gara however gara would emerge
unharmed at least physically we also had
the nine tails attack on the leaf
village while there were obviously
dozens of unnamed deaths there were four
big ones namely iruka lost both of his
parents ikaku and kohari in the attack
meanwhile kushina would be mortally
wounded by the fox and minato the fourth
hokage would sacrifice his own life to
use the reaper death seal to implant the
nine tails within his son naruto also
placing a fragment of himself and
kushina's energy within him to ensure
they can at least meet their son in some
way in the future furthermore while not
the most important death in the series
harrison's wife bilako was also killed
by obito during this attack nono yakushi
was a leaf anbu who ran the orphanage
that kabuto grew up in years after
kabuto became a shinobi he was sent on a
mission where nono attacked him she no
longer recognized him and in a panic
kabuto mortally wounded her and all of
this was orchestrated by donzo even
going so far as to brainwash nono he had
been sending her pictures of kabuto
after he had left the orphanage and
slowly replaced them with someone else
until she no longer recognized him after
learning the truth of the situation from
orochimaru kabuto would go on to join
rochimaru the kaguya clan descendants of
kagiaotsuki some of whom specialized in
bone manipulation abilities were
entirely wiped out by the hidden mist
with the exception of kimi modo shi-sui
jihad was said to have the strongest
sharon gone ability of all and after
danzo stole one of his eyes he would
give the other to hitachi to ensure
donso couldn't have it then taking his
own life this was also in the hopes that
he could awaken itachi's mangakyo
sharingan making him strong enough to
save the village from the upcoming
uchihaku speaking of which this was also
about the time when hitachi would go on
to slaughter the uchiha with obito with
the exception of sasuke obito and itachi
himself all the uchiha would be killed
to avoid a coup that they were plotting
against the leaf village avoiding this
would have essentially also avoided a
civil war hiyashi huga being hinata's
father killed the head ninja of the
hidden cloud an act which required
retribution as such his twin brother
hizashi huga offered his own life to
save hiashi and protect his family
obviously being a huge factor in negi's
disdain for hinata early on in the
series jugo biwa was a member of the
seven ninja swordmen of the mists who
would go on to join the akatsuki and be
partnered with hitachi they were sent on
a mission to extract the three tails
from the fourth mizukage yagura
karatachi however jugo would be mortally
wounded in the process that said yagura
himself would also die when his tail
beast was taken from him and just
wrapping up this era the akatsuki member
kakuzu also killed his unnamed partner
for being annoying hisame another akosky
member killed the leaf cipher division
to avoid them sending intel and also
killed fugu suikazon who was another
member of the seven ninja swordsmen of
the mist and finally we have kaizen who
is anari's stepfather who would be
publicly executed by a gato and lead
into one of the first arcs in naruto
haku was an orphan from the land of
water who was someone that naruto
heavily empathized with and really
showed off the important message within
the series that we wouldn't only have
evil antagonists but we could also have
decent people who just happen to be on
the opposite side of a conflict haku
found himself with no meaning after
being orphaned and was approached by
zabuza to become his weapon as haku had
the extremely rare ice kekagenkai haku
ultimately agreed to do this as it would
fill him with some sense of purpose and
this would all result on his famous
battle with naruto and sasuke on the
soon to be great naruto bridge however
haku would die shortly after by jumping
in front of zabuza as kakashi attempted
to stab him with the chidori gato was a
shipping magnate and drug trafficker who
tried to isolate the land of waves by
preventing the building of the bridge
however he was killed by zabuza speaking
of zabu zamamochi was one of these seven
swordsmen of the mist and gained the
name demon of the mist after he killed a
hundred students at the ninja academy
before he even enrolled himself during
the reign of the fourth mizukaze the
bloody mist zabuza rallied a coup
however this failed and led zabuzad into
fleeing and working for gato eventually
landing him in his battle against
kakashi the injuries from which would
take his life
rasa was the fourth kazekage and garu's
father his own village hidden in the
sand was in the middle of an economic
bust because basically everyone was
hiring the leaf village for jobs and
their own village was not getting much
work as such he agreed to help rochimaru
attack the leaf however during the
attack orochimaru would betray him and
stab him with a sword shiore is the
young san ninja that hirochimaru killed
and assumed the identity of prior to his
battle with sasuke in the forest of
death shigure mirarei and bayu are all
ninjas from the hidden reign who
confronted gara tamari and kankuro in
the force death and were the first
people that we saw gara kill in that
extremely gruesome scene it was one
thing when we saw orochimaru kill
someone as you know he's a villain
however seeing a contestant so brutally
and savagely destroy his opponents like
that definitely set gara apart from the
crowd
of course the san ninja weren't the only
antagonistic groups within the tuning
exams we also had team dosu working for
urochimaru and representing the village
hidden in sound doso kinota's abilities
all revolved around sound waves
themselves and he was more easily able
to detect sound than others however he
challenges gara to a fight and is
ultimately killed for doing so hayate
gekko was a leif jonan who's acting as
the proctor for the tuning exams he
spies on both kabuto and baki when they
become suspicious but when he chooses to
actually confront baki he is killed very
quickly another moment which definitely
showed off the more cutthroat tendencies
of the sand
zaku abumi and kin tsuchi are the final
members of team dosu these sound village
ninjas working for orochimaru both of
whom would eventually be sacrificed for
orochi maru's impure world reincarnation
specifically zaku would be used to bring
back hashirama while kin would be used
for tobii rama and of course orochimaru
would use these two resurrected kage to
fight against hiruzin shiva and midori
are ninja who approach gara during the
tuning exam to try and convince him to
throw his next match against sasuke
however gara is a little bit insulted by
this and kills both of them on the spot
and it's honestly getting to the point
where i feel like the majority of
characters on this list were killed by
gara one of the most impactful deaths in
early naruto is easily hirozin sarutobi
the third hokage when morochimaru
attacked the leaf and resurrected two of
the prior hokage hirozin used the reaper
death seal to sacrifice himself in order
to stop orochimaru he was ultimately
unable to seal him entirely so he
instead decided to seal his hands and
leave him unable to use them going
forward hirozin was probably the first
big character death in the entire series
sure we had haku but this was a more
prominent member of the leaf village the
prominent member of the village he was
the hokage he was someone powerful that
everyone in the village looked up to and
respected and just like how haku showed
us that people are a product of
circumstance hirozin showed us that
there are some dangerous ninja out there
and that sacrifices would need to be
made to progress into the future of
course this rank of hokage is something
that naruto aspired towards and this was
a phenomenal representation of the
things a hokage might have to do
next we have the sound four with girobo
kiramaru tayuya sakon and ukan yes there
are five members of the sound four sort
of each of these members were prisoners
of arochimaru who were forced into
battle royals and proved to be the
strongest being allowed to live and made
into bodyguards for surviving each was
also given a curse seal as well to make
them even stronger than they normally
would be all of the sound 4 were sent to
recover sasuke for rochimaru jirobo was
the more muscle-bound character who
specialized in physical strength and
draining chakra from his enemies however
choji managed to defeat him after eating
his chakra enhancing pills and going
full butterfly mode kiramato had six
arms and spider-like abilities being
able to spin webs which allowed him to
trap or detect enemies this webbing
could also be hardened into weapons or
arrows if needed kiramaru was killed
when neji struck his heart with a gentle
fist tayuya was my personal favorite of
the sound 4 because i'm mostly a sucker
for sound-based abilities
most of her abilities revolve around her
demonic flute which she uses to control
her doki which were giant ogre monsters
she can also put her opponents into
genjutsu with the flute as well she
originally was battling shikamaru and
they were evenly matched however tamari
shows up and turns the tide of the
battle tayyip begins running away but
tamari uses quick beheading dance to
devastate the forest and slash the
escaping to yuya leaving her dead under
a pile of sliced trees something to note
here is that this is one of the first
times that the sand is making an effort
to really help out the leaf and the last
two members of the sound 4 are sakon and
ukan
twins who shared a body when using the
cursed seal they split into two and are
able to overwhelm most of the leaf ninja
that they encounter
their main ability was molecular
manipulation they could basically
deconstruct their own bodies to the
molecular level enter the opponents and
alter their cells to kill them however
once inside of someone they also shared
the damage that person takes
so when ukan is inside of kiba kiba
stabs his own hand to wound wukon as
well forcing him to leave his body this
leads both sakon and ukan into a battle
with kankuro in which they become
trapped inside of kankuro's puppet which
has no cells to dive into and they are
impaled while locked inside and now that
we've covered all five of the sound for
let's talk about their leader the sixth
member
of the sound four that of course being
kimimaru much like haku
had a special kekagenkai which allowed
him to use bone-based jutsu the leader
of his clan had locked him up fearing
his abilities however this wouldn't end
up being something he had to worry about
for very long because the clan was
attacked by the missed village and wiped
out entirely leaving kimimaru as the
last one alive he was eventually found
by rochimaru and joined his ranks
fighting and defeating the other members
of the sound 4 to become their leader
orochimaru was even going to make
kimimaru his new host which kimimaru was
totally okay with because he was someone
who finally gave him meaning but when
kimimaru became afflicted with the
disease orochimaru lost all interest in
him
speaking of that illness it's exactly
this illness that would eventually lead
to his death as he was mere inches away
from killing gada in their fight this
whole section is great because it shows
both that the main cast isn't the only
one that can deal with people we have
even choji coming in clutch here and not
only that but not even the leaf village
is the only one responsible for this
victory the sand village comes in and
shows that there's this bond forming
between these two that used to be
enemies to the point that one of them
basically did a terror attack on the
other overcoming these villains as a
group is a great symbol of what is to
come kagero jigamo kamakiri and arashi
were members of the once great fuma clan
which much like haku and kimimaru's
clans were wiped out they were
approached by orochimaru who offered
them a chance at bringing their clan
back into power they began to guard
rochimaru's hideout in the land of rice
fields kaguro would become fatally
wounded trying to protect jigimo and
kamahiri and would be brought by them to
orochimaru to beg him to save her he
refused however because of their failure
to kill leaf ninja they attacked
arochimaru in a rage and were quickly
killed as a result with it soon after
being revealed that this was actually
arashi in disguise and not the real
urotimaru that said after killing
kamakiri and jigemo he did decide to
heal kagero she would go on to bind her
own heartbeat to narutos in an attempt
to kill him by stopping her own however
sakura arrived at the last minute to cut
the tie that connected them finally
arashi would die after a fight with
naruto where he was caught in a cave in
that said arashi had no intention of
leaving the cave as he was disgusted by
his own actions and felt this was a way
for him to repent raiga kurosuki is a
member of the swordsmen of the mist who
defected from his village and became a
crime boss along with ron maru when
confronted by naruto and his group
ranmaru decides to side with them for a
moment betraying raga and naruto ends up
knocking raga off a cliff during his
fall he ends his own life hoping that in
doing so he can free ranmaru from his
current life of crime
misumitsurugi acted as a bodyguard for
one of rochimaru's former scientists
amachi he would also go on to be killed
by ino using her mind transfer jutsu and
forcing him to end his own life
similarly yoro yakiro would also work
for himachi and was killed by shino the
third hoshikage was killed by akahoshi's
men after refusing to allow them to
perform star training because he thought
it would lead to too many of his people
being put at risk natsuhi similarly fell
to one of akohoshi's traps and would be
killed as well but before her death she
performed a jutsu which allowed her to
return as a spirit briefly and assist
naruto by giving him a boost to his
chakra and even allowing him to fly and
defeat akahoshi ruiga and jiga were
members of the janine a trio of brother
ninja who had special techniques however
none of these members were trusting of
each other leading to jiga killing ruiga
and jiga himself being killed by hinata
his own abilities allowed him to play
around with magnetism and hinata would
boost his chakra flow to increase this
causing him to be crushed by a torrent
of metal that was drawn into him genno
was an old man who intended to blow up
the leaf village however after meeting
naruto and seeing his own son in him his
intentions begin to sway he died from
old age during his encounter with naruto
and choji shura was the leader of a
crime group called the shinobazu he also
fought with an umbrella shura was
looking for a treasure and kidnapped and
beat several people in an attempt to
find it however he would be killed by
naruto's versailles we also have menma a
ninja with the ability to erase memories
he committed some terrible atrocities
and wiped his own mind so that he would
be able to escape the guilt he was
feeling
he eventually regained his memories
though and as the village he was staying
at was about to be destroyed by a flood
he sacrificed himself by blowing up a
mine shaft with him inside in order to
stop the flood and save the village in
an attempt to repent that brings us to
the final group of ninja to be killed in
the original naruto series the four
celestial symbol men a group of four
people who tried to harness the power of
shukaku to revive the founder of their
village seimei kujaku the only female
member was killed by tamari and launched
into a river
ryugan was trapped by kankuro's puppets
and impaled suiko was killed by gara and
the leader hoki sacrificed his body to
revive seimei speaking of seimei they
were known for founding takumi village a
place renowned for selling weapons to
other villages while seimei himself was
considered takami's greatest weapon upon
revival he made a new ultimate body from
the weapons of his fallen comrades which
unfortunately didn't stand up to gara
who killed him with his spear of shukaku
and finally we have reached shibudin i
won't be covering the majority of
reincarnation deaths because if they
were brought back to life they were
pretty much all sealed or re-killed
after that now almost immediately in
shipodin we see what the akatsuki are
trying to do as we see them removing
these seven-tailed beast from foo thus
killing the jachiriki and much of the
opening deaths will most likely be
related to the akatsuki mukade was a san
ninja who was sacrificed and turned into
a version of kisame which was used to
stall mike guy's team from progressing
ultimately being killed by might guy
yura similarly was a sand ninja who was
being used as a sleeper agent for sasori
he was eventually used as a replacement
for hitachi and killed by naruto's big
bal resengan gara much like phu was
killed when shukaku was extracted from
him however granny chio ultimately
sacrificed herself to give him a second
chance at life sasuri was the first
akatsuki member that is active that we
see killed during his battle with sakura
and chio chio manages to destroy his
core and ends his life
chiriku was one of the 12 guardian ninja
of the land of fire's daimyo and he was
ultimately killed by an akatsuki duo of
hidon and kakuzu yugito another
jinchuriki this time for the two tails
was killed when she had her tailed beast
removed from her asama sarutobi a leaf
jonine and the son of hiruzin as well as
the leader of shikamaru squad had an
incredibly tragic death at the hands of
the akatsuki member hidan sparking a
massive growth in shikamaru speaking of
hiran shikamaru gets his revenge by
luring hidan into a pitfall filled with
explosives he is then left to die from
starvation or thirst under all the
rubble kalkuzu hiron's partner had five
hearts which needed to be destroyed
before he could be actually killed once
they were all taken care of though
kakashi finishes him off with the
chidori orochimaru the first big bad of
the series was temporarily killed at the
hands of sasuke when he tried to take
over his body he would of course be
resurrected later in the story though
sasuke also had a hand in the death of
the akatsuki member daedara when deidera
realizes that he couldn't win in this
fight he opts to use c0 a massive
explosion that took his own life in an
attempt to kill sasuke as well
an idea which ultimately failed however
it did result in the death of manda
sasuke snake who was used as a shield
jiraya one of the leaf sannin and the
mentor for both minato and naruto would
go to investigate pain he would come
face to face with all six pains and
ultimately be killed in battle but not
before being able to send an encoded
message back to the leaf to warn them
about his findings
naturally though naruto isn't the only
one to lose his idol here as sasuke
confronts itachi and hitachi passes away
due to his illness hiroshi han and
utakata are all ginchurikis of the four
five and six tails respectively and as
you might guess they were all killed
when their tailed beasts were removed
from them by the akatsuki during payne's
attack on the leaf village kakashi and
shizune were each killed kakashi while
protecting choji and his father and
shizune after payne reads her mind to
find naruto fakasaku the old frog who
partnered with naruto during his fight
with payne was also killed in that fight
as well however nagato eventually goes
to sacrifice his own life using the rene
rebirth to bring everyone back
soon after this sasuke comes face to
face with donzo the man who runs the
leaf on bu and who has stolen the eyes
of several uchiha making it pretty
fitting that sasuke would be the one to
take him out kisame who is hitachi's
partner also meets his fate when he is
defeated by might guy he's held captive
for a moment and rather than wanting to
be interrogated he summons sharks to
devour him whole konan the final member
of the trio jaraya raised in the hidden
reign and one of the final members of
the ikotsky along with setsu and obito
was killed by obito so that he could
retrieve nagato's renagon
fu and torune are ninja who were held
captive by obito obito wanted to have
kabuto demonstrate his summoning impure
world reincarnation technique however he
had no bodies to do so as such torune
was killed and foo was used as a
sacrifice and replaced by torune white
zetsu killed several medical ninja in
order to infiltrate ninja alliance bases
these included toyoso takamaru hino and
two others
wait zetsu himself would be killed by
sasuke after obtaining his eternal
mangekyo sharingan as a way to test his
new abilities and as we approach the
endgame we have the revival of the ten
tales this monster fired a bijudama
towards the shinobi alliance
headquarters killing shikaku nara who is
shikamaru's father inowichi yamanaka who
is eno's father and mabui the fourth
recage's assistant and like
the first two were sad but losing mabui
was a true tragedy those weren't the
only ones to lose their lives to the ten
tales though as it fired a piece of wood
at naruto and neji jumped in his way to
protect him ultimately leading to neji's
death which to me has always felt like a
death that just didn't need to happen
and believe it or not there are only
three relevant deaths left in the entire
series the first with obito one of the
big bads who attempted to redeem himself
by sacrificing his life to save naruto
and kakashi second being modera the
other main antagonist who died from
having all the tail beasts and the
ghetto statue removed from him when
kaguya was resurrected and finally
in that moment not only did modera die
but of course
the quality of writing in the series
died with him but that might just be me
but that is it all of the relevant
deaths in naruto and shippuden i
probably missed a few minor characters
here or there who were either pointless
or reanimations but i promise you if
they're not here they just probably
don't matter we covered over 150 people
so please cut me some slack for not
mentioning ninja number 4887
in the background of episode 368
that does raise the question though
which death in naruto was your favorite
or which do you think was the most
impactful for you or the story as a
whole let me know down in the comments
and if you enjoyed this video leave a
like as well doing those things will
help this video a lot with the youtube
algorithm of course if you aren't
subscribed to the channel be sure to hit
that notification bell to select all
notifications so you can see more
content as it comes out as i mentioned
before i also have a video on my own
channel talking about deaths in anime
which will be linked down below i think
you will really enjoy it if you take the
time to check it out and if you are
looking to follow the channel a little
bit closer you can always check out our
twitter and instagram at anime uproar or
you can follow myself at excellionyt
but for now thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time remember to
stay excellent
[Music]
[Music]
okay